this variety marks one year of the war
in Ukraine as the anniversary approaches
the US has warned China of consequences
if it sends weapons and ammunition to
help Russia's invasion of Ukraine for
more on this and a look back at the year
joined by the former U.S national
security adviser and former ambassador
to the UN that's John Bolton always a
pleasure Mr Bolton thank you for joining
us before we start
um did I hear that you've thrown or
about to throw your hat in the ring to
be the next president of the United
States
well I'm thinking about it I looked at
it very seriously in 2016 and decided
not to but I was very concerned about
the Donald Trump's comments some weeks
back that the U.S Constitution should be
terminated so that he could be declared
the winner of the 2020 election and I
wasn't satisfied with the response of
the people who are considering running
so I thought I ought to be serious about
it because I think it's important to end
this idea that the 2020 election was
stolen or that Donald Trump really has
any claim on the Loyalty of
conservatives or Republicans
if you run
ramji well I wouldn't run unless I
thought I could win I wouldn't do this
simply to make the point it's a very
arduous process as I think people know
so it requires some due diligence before
making the decision and and that's
really what I'm in the process of doing
now
when will you decide
well I think in the next few months the
process is a little bit slower than I
anticipated it would be there are a lot
of people who are looking at getting in
and one thing I think we all want to
avoid is to have so many people in the
race that Trump is able to slip between
them and get the nomination I don't
think he will be the nominee ultimately
anyway and I don't think he would win if
God forbid he did become the Republican
nominee
let's talk about China two things what
are they up to when it comes to
supporting Russia against Ukraine and of
course these spy balloons as well choose
which one you want to First
well in terms of support for Russia I
know secretary blinken uh warned them
about supplying weapons honestly for the
past year China has been giving Russia
enormous support already there's no
doubt in my mind that sanctioned Russian
financial institutions are laundering
money through China's extraordinarily
opaque Financial system and China has
substantially increased its purchases of
Russian oil and natural gas to make up
for revenues lost in other sales I don't
doubt that in more clandestine ways
China's also been helping Russia perhaps
assisting North Korea in its sales of
artillery and ammunition and in many
other ways the idea that somehow China
and Russia have split over the invasion
of Ukraine has always been wrong it's
really quite the opposite they're
forming a closer and closer on time and
it it's a problem for the West as a
whole going forward the the Chinese
balloon which I think was very badly
missed handled by the Biden
Administration is significant in its own
right the people theorize that one
reason they're interested in balloon
surveillance over the United States is
that in the event of War people have
spoken for a long time about China's
anti-satellite program being designed to
take out American eyes in the sky so
they would expect we would then do the
same to theirs and balloon surveillance
is a substitute a poor substitute I
think but something to look at so this
this should be this balloon should be a
wake-up call for people in the United
States and Europe and elsewhere who
don't think China is a threat in the
21st century in in my view China is the
existential threat in the 21st century
but I thought China had all these sort
of technology in space where they could
read number plates from the moon or
whatever why do they need to have these
balloons around
right well their their uh cameras may
not be as good as ours but but even if
they are as I say in a circumstance in
conflict or in pre-conflict crisis when
the sides were destroying their
satellite observation capabilities
having some alternative high-flying
aircraft like the U2 that we have or
these balloons could be at least
something of a substitute and Chinese
research may be moving faster ahead on
that than ours has been but to be sure
this is a serious matter but it's
indicative of the extraordinarily
widespread nature of Chinese
surveillance efforts against the United
States and and the West as a whole
with some President Biden right to say
shoot him down
but frankly he should have he should
have shot it down before it crossed over
into Alaska according to press reports
we had actually been tracking that
balloon since it left the island of Hana
and south of the Chinese Mainland about
a week before it showed up over the
Aleutian Islands I think the presumption
should be an unidentified aircraft that
we have no idea what the payload is or
what its capabilities are get shot down
before it endangers Americans
and you think that there was similar
incidents during the Trump
Administration
well we we were certainly I was
certainly not notified of it the I have
had a uh uh highly classified briefing
by the office of the Director of
National Intelligence for which I thank
the administration so I'm somewhat
constrained in what I can say but I
think I think it's clear that there have
been a lot of unidentified phenomena in
past years that it's been observed but
uh but our analysts have not been able
to understand what it is I think this
balloon and the research that's been
done in the past couple of years
indicates that there's probably a lot
more of this than we knew in the past so
we we learned from that we increased the
capacity of our radar and other
detection systems and uh just to try and
make our perimeter more secure than it
has been
and just to go back
to Weaponry to Russia in the war against
Ukraine
well it wouldn't be surprising or you
know non-governmental organizations in
China volunteering their assistance to
the Russians I wouldn't take anything
either one of them says at face value
and the fact that the United States
government is only commenting on it now
doesn't mean that it's just started
right now China has a vested interest in
this on taunt with Russia the only
disagreement between the two countries
over the war in Ukraine I think is
probably Chinese disappointment that the
Russians aren't doing better
okay thank you very much indeed for
joining us as always Mr Bolton look
forward to seeing you in the studio
again soon thank you